y el chavismo toma hoy la única
institución que no controlaba la
asamblea nacional de venezuela el 6 de
diciembre en medio de una abstención de
casi el 70 por ciento de los votantes
del país llevó a cabo unas elecciones
parlamentarias sin la participación de
los opositores y en las que los
partidarios de nicolás maduro ganaron el
poder pero siguieron perdiendo
credibilidad eeuu la unión europea y
decenas de países de américa latina sólo
reconocen la asamblea nacional de
mayoría opositora escogida en 2015 cuyo
periodo debió terminar este 2021 como lo
dicta la constitución sin embargo el
pasado 26 de diciembre los legisladores
aprobaron extender su mandato por un año
más al calificar los recientes comicios
como un fraude pero para el presidente
maduro dicha extensión es
inconstitucional tanto maduro como todos
los poderes del estado ignoran las
decisiones de la asamblea nacional
declarada en desacato desde 2016 por el
tribunal supremo de justicia a raíz de
la juramentación de tres diputados cuya
elección fue suspendida en 2017 la misma
corte dejó sin competencias al
parlamento por incumplir
varias de sus sentencias lo que desató
una crisis constitucional que algo hizo
las protestas contra el gobierno en
medio de las cuales maduro llamó a
convocar una asamblea nacional
constituyente a pesar de ataques por
parte de seguidores chavistas los
parlamentarios opositores siguieron
sesionando y en 2019 escogieron a juan
guaidó como líder de la cámara quien
luego se proclamó como presidente
interino de venezuela tras unas
elecciones presidenciales que dieron a
maduro un segundo mandato y que fueron
tildadas de fraude
apoyado por la comunidad internacional
why do prometió sacar a maduro del poder
pero dos años después no logró su
objetivo en cambio varios líderes
políticos han tenido que abandonar el
país al sentirse perseguidos por el
gobierno